servus christoph und servus christoph
ich hätte ein paar fragen an dich feld
ich bin ein großer fan hatte aus der
teams verkehr stur in frankfurt auch die
möglichkeiten die ein bild zu machen
cool da noch mal ein großes dankeschön
problem
das bild und zwar habe ich bei dir auf
facebook sehen dass dubai
lieblingsbücher rogowska stehen hast ja
meine frage wäre zog so regelmäßig oder
ist das mehr vegan job
mit was mit dem einsatz zockst du nachts
war bisher dein größter gewinn der nur
ausgelöst kurse für mich brennend
interessieren wir ja dann der berühmte
facebook ja hast du den ernsthaft
gegessen oder hast du den müll geworfen
weil ich hätte definitiv gekotzt weil so
der menge an brot dann würde mich auch
interessieren
ich bin großer zocker
mehr oder weniger sorgst du hast du
aktuelle konsolen wie die ps3 oder 360
wenn ja was sagst du
shooter
fifa
rennspiele ja
danke mich wieder antwort macht weiter
so ich bin ein treuer selbstverständlich
gut dreimal so
war die erste frage nochmal auch hier
noch mit dem mit dem mit dem spiel
wichtig sein ja ich war lange zeit sehr
spielsüchtig und
book of ra habe ich dann immer gespielt
die auf 20 cent fängt man am meisten
sonne oder manchmal auch oft auf zähne
an was man warten also machen will 15
euro dafür kann man in die hölle in
meiner religion
ja mein höchster gewinn war tatsächlich
die fünf forscher willkommen sind als
ich bücher hatte also 500 euro auf 10
cent war es aber nur der automat war
schon abgeschrieben habe schon mal
anders angesetzt seien auf einmal kam es
500 euro waren
das wäre noch für die frage ich jetzt
nicht mehr so viel weil ich ja ich bin
vater geworden und jetzt geht es in die
familienkasse und da muss man halt
irgendwie abstriche machen so ganz klar
sollte es keinen spaß mehr so richtig
leider
außerdem gefällt mir diese neue book of
ra software nicht wir haben jetzt
umgestellt und die ziemlich scheiße
gott sei dank kann das so noch schön zum
jahresanfang die neue software die man
extra noch perfekt schon auf den sack
gehen das hat mir leichter gemacht nicht
mehr zu viel so viel zu spielen sagt
niemals nie ja
ich gehe aber und zumal schon über kommt
es nicht und dann die zweite frage
war mit dem feld wobei der natürlich
nicht gegessen alle meine fans sie es
nachgemacht haben
hhf vollidioten hat ja sowieso
ich habe nicht vergessen kann ich hab s
weggeschmissen die armen kinder in der
dritten welt verhungern und ich weiß den
tonnen brot weg ja so bin ich halt sorry
dritte frage
war noch mal
aber mit zocken ja ich im moment zog ich
gar nicht ich zock angry birds auf dem
iphone das war's sie haben wie zuhause
warum auch immer mit einer festplatte
mit allen spielen drauf das ganz cool
mal aber sonst ich hätte drei machen
lieber nicht weil dann kommt das album
dann wird das album jetzt zum beispiel
gar nicht draußen christoph alex lacey
drei zu hause aber wieder erstehen habe
den teufel in der wohnung habt könnt ihr
so ein buch automaten hinstellen würde
einfach nicht mehr gehen das war's